[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about two of my favorite
ongoing anime and manga along with of
course attack on Titan and a few others
my hero Academy our boku no hero and the
seven deadly sins or naina - no taizai
as I've been watching the anime and
reading the manga for both series I've
noticed that even though they are both
popular shown in franchises with
fantastical elements they are actually
very different in terms of their
approach to the story and the characters
but even though they are different both
approaches work really well and both
series have attracted a large audience
for that reason even though they follow
a very different structure both series
are great at what they do
and in this video I will explain how the
two series differ but still manage to be
awesome
in their own way feel free to give me
your thoughts about my hero academia and
the seven that he sends down in the
comments and after watching this video
be sure to check out nock stock whose
new video comparing meliodas from the
seven deadly sins and Kirito from sword
art online NOx and I worked on both of
these videos together so his video is
like a companion video to this one and
of course if you want to see more videos
like this one be sure to leave a like to
let me know if you are new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
Detroit smash that notification bell and
we post daily content on Twitter and
Instagram so be sure to follow us at
anime uproar now of course the overall
setting and story of boku no hero and
seven deadly sins is very different as
is to be expected from two different
franchises so that's not what I'll be
looking into here the first major thing
that I want to talk about is the
protagonist or main character in both
series and how vastly different Deku and
melly ODIs are as characters both of
these series have a very large cast of
characters and as the story develops you
could argue that more than one
protagonist emerges but for now let's
talk about deco and meliodas
as the clear main protagonists in the
early
part of the story when we first meet
deku he is a boy who desperately wants
to become a hero but in a world where
the vast majority of people have quirks
or special abilities that allow them to
do extraordinary things
Deku is Quercus he is often put down and
mocked by others because of his lack of
any special abilities and in that sense
we could say that he is an underpowered
protagonist Deku is an underdog and that
has its own unique appeal those of us
watching or reading the manga obviously
don't have quirks and we've all been
underdogs at some point in our lives so
it is easy to relate to Deku it's easy
to put ourselves in his shoes and you
can't help but admire his ambition and
determination to still become a great
hero despite not even having a quirk it
makes sense for someone with an insanely
powerful quirk like boku go to want to
test his strength train his abilities
and become a hero but an underdog like
deck who going up against far stronger
opponents and still refusing to give up
is definitely something to admire now of
course many people have argued that once
he receives one for all from all might
deck who suddenly goes from an underdog
to being overpowered and while I can see
the logic behind that we also have to
remember that Deku needs to go through a
lot of pain and suffering in order to
learn to use his quirk so this power
isn't just handed to him like that guy
in izakaya
smartphone all seven magical powers
really with Deku as the protagonist we'd
the viewers and readers get to go on his
journey along with him from the very
beginning we see him rise from an
underdog to a contender we see him
trained to get stronger we see him
evolve as a person and so on and if this
is a formula that works as far as shown
in protagonists go then how can seven
deadly sins possibly be good Meli ODIs
and Dec who couldn't be more different
when we first meet Mel Yoda's we think
he is just a harmless fun-loving owner
of the boar hat bar but that lasts for
less than one episode before we learned
that he is actually the captain of the
seven deadly sins and the seven deadly
sins are among the strongest warriors in
all of birth
Hanyu at the end of episode 1 we already
get a glimpse of melioidosis incredible
power as he easily defeats apprentice
Holy Night Lord Twigg oh the kind of man
that only his own mother and Knox Taku
could love as the series goes on we
realized that not only is meliodas
insanely powerful and let's face it
overpowered compared to the vast
majority of the opponent's he faces but
he is also over 3,000 years old so
unlike deku we don't need meliodas
anywhere near the beginning of his
journey so how can meliodas possibly be
a good protagonist if we can't relate to
him we the viewers and readers are
nowhere near that strong or that old
clearly Mellie Otis is a completely
different type of shown and protagonist
from Deku but he is still a great
protagonist
maybe it's because I'm no longer in high
school or because I just have my own
unique tastes but it actually took me
quite a while to warm up to Deku as a
good protagonist
however with Mellie Otis I loved the guy
right away in the beginning of the boku
no hero story we can tell the Deku is a
good guy but we spent a lot of time
watching him deal with being an underdog
struggling crying and so on this is
something that we've seen many times
before in anime Shinji from Neon Genesis
Evangelion and Renton from arica 7 come
to mind right away and of course ash
whenever he is trying to give away
another one of his Pokemon so when I
first started watching boku no hero I
was under the impression that Deku isn't
a very unique character just a
stereotypical underdog protagonist I
changed my mind about that once I read
the manga and saw deque who really
developed as a character but I was
fascinated by melioidosis character
right from the very beginning I loved
the twist at the end of the first
episode and the first chapter where we
learned that this small carefree guy
with an over-the-top sense of humor is
actually the captain of the seven deadly
sins instead of watching him go from an
underdog to a great warrior when we meet
Mele Oda's he is already one of the
greatest warriors in the world and yet
the seven deadly sins still manages to
be a great story that's because even
though the protagonist is overpowered
the story stays interesting the plot is
not about
watching the main character train and
groves step-by-step but rather it is
about a quest and the first important
quest is to reunite all the members of
the seven deadly sins since every member
of the seven deadly sins is very strong
it is still interesting to see all of
them interacting with Mellie Otis and I
especially loved the relationship
between Mellie Otis and bond the
interesting thing about Mellie Otis is
not seeing how he goes from weak to
strong but rather the mystery of how he
became so strong in the first place
nevertheless getting stronger or
powering up is an important shown intro
and the way that the seven deadly sins
includes this trope is by making Mellie
Otis a demon who at times loses control
of his power which makes him stronger
but also more dangerous on top of that
we later learned that the vast majority
of melioidosis power has been sealed
away in order to prevent him from losing
control and so once he retrieves this
power he is able to power up even more
you might think that having such an Opie
protagonist would make the show boring
since he'll have no trouble with any
villain but by adding this dimension
that meliodas has to fight against
himself and his own demonic nature and
by introducing extremely strong villains
later on in the series including the 10
commandments who had been sealed away in
the coffin of eternal darkness for 3,000
years the story of the seven deadly sins
stays interesting even though Mellie
Otis is incredibly strong as are the
other members of the seven deadly sins
they still face major challenges both in
terms of their own inner demons pun
intended and in terms of outside threats
like the ten commandments beyond just
Milly ODIs and deku the different
approaches to character development in
the two series follow a similar pattern
in boku no hero most of the main cast
are relatively normal high school
students so they're all young their
journey is just beginning and there
isn't too much that the series can do in
terms of complex backstory don't get me
wrong some of the characters do have
interesting backstories including show
Totoro ki in particular but most of the
main cast in the seven deadly sins are
much older the youngest members of the
seven deadly sins are in their 40s while
others are hundreds and even thousands
of years old so of course
the seven deadly sins has a lot more
room to explore the rich histories and
backstories of its characters whereas
boku no hero has to focus mostly on the
present that's not to say that one of
these approaches is good and the other
is bad they are just different I
absolutely love that in the seven deadly
sins a lot of time is spent on the
backstories of the characters which
gives us a better understanding of them
as people and allows us to see their
progression on the other hand in boku no
hero we get to see the personalities of
the characters being shaped in real time
in the present moment and this is
extremely compelling as well you feel
like you are growing up together with
these characters instead of getting to
know them when they are fully formed
adults which allows us to connect with
them on another level and this is what I
find so interesting these two series
take very different approaches to
character development including the
protagonist and main character himself
and yet I really enjoy both of them
because they are great at what they do
we are introduced to the important
characters in completely different ways
but in both cases the characters are
compelling enough for us to feel a
connection to them the story moves
forward without becoming stale because
of the excellent world building and
character development and whether we're
looking at the mystery of what happens
next to Deku and how he becomes the
greatest hero or the mystery of what
really happened in the holy war 3,000
years ago in each case the mystery draws
us in and keeps us guessing the manga
for both series is far ahead of the
anime and as I am caught up to both of
them I can tell you that neither series
has gotten less interesting as time goes
on if anything both manga have gotten
better after the events that are covered
in the first season of the anime and I
can't wait to see how some of the
upcoming arcs are going to be adapted in
anime form but that is all from me on
this topic let me know what you guys
think do you enjoy both of these series
despite the fact that they are so
different and do you happen to prefer
one over the other if so let me know why
down below I always love hearing from
you don't forget to check out nock stock
whose new video comparing Mellie Otis
and Kirito as I said we worked on both
of these videos together so his video is
like a companion video to this one if
you enjoyed this type of comparison
video and you want to see more in the
future be sure to leave a like to let me
know if you are new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and Detroit smash
that notification bell and be sure to
check us out on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar as always thank you all so
much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]